Ladies and gentlemen, Amy Schumer.
(audience applauding)
Oh my God!
I'm so pumped.
Thank you for having me on, Drew.
Oh my God!
I've just loved and admired you for so long.
When we were like early in Flower Films,
like everyone at our production company knew about you.
We were obsessed with you.
And then you did "Inside Amy Schumer".
And like, I'm thinking about your life, Amy,
and I'm thinking about like, you know,
you do Inside Amy Schumer and you write books,
and if it's like a pandemic, you're like,
"I'm gonna make a cooking show with my husband",
you do stand up, if you're pregnant,
you share it with people in these really artistic ways.
You know, you make "Expecting Amy".
We'll get into "Life and Beth", which I've been watching.
And, I almost want advice
from you for myself and anyone watching,
like, how do you prolifically
just turn all of your life
into something that is artistic and a shared experience?
Well, I just first have to say that your support...
This is like, not 15 or 20 years ago with Flower Films.
Like your company, you were the first one to reach out to me
and wanna make something with me.
I mean, that's really the truth and that's a big deal.
Whoa, whoa!
I don't know what's happening with the tape, but I loved it.
Thank you.
And we did this thing.
It was like a sketch that would've wound up
on my sketch show, but what we made it together,
and it was like about donating eggs,
and it was like this really strange little short film
that I made with your company.
And also, you have been such a huge inspiration to me,
and I think, you know, to everybody, yeah.
Oh my God, stop, please.
And so, there is a lot of you in me.
Thank you.
Yes.
And I'm sorry if that's inappropriate.
Well, I want to be inside of you,
So that's good.
Please be inside me.
Please, I need you inside me.
But, you know, hearing you say it like that,
it really does sound like I do really
use my own life and mine it for all the value that...
And I feel like we all need to do that in some way.
You know, all this trauma,
all these life lessons, these joys,
it's like what are we learning from it?
And so, it's just as therapeutic for me
which is why this book that's coming out
that I edited and helped compile
with Christy Turlington called "Arrival Stories",
it's 20 different women.
It's essays where we described the births of our children
or the moments that we became mothers.
Oh, thank you.
Wow, it's right there.
Oh my gosh!
I haven't even seen it.
(audience applauding)
Yeah, like that is something that...
You know, I think, my best friends,
we hadn't discussed our births with each other.
It's like this thing that sometimes gets like buried
and as women you're like taught
to not really share that much.
And so, you know, we are like,
we're going the other way with it,
because it's the talking about it and writing about it
that you do start to open yourself up
and sharing these stories is what helps each other, I think.
And do you think that you are the person
that you put out there?
Is there something that would like surprise us about you?
Like, you know, what do you do on a Saturday,
if you have no obligations, what are you doing?
Every night, we read to Gene,
and then Chris and I just watch TV.
I heard throuples are trending.
I'm just saying, maybe I could come in on this relationship
because that's exactly what I wanna do,
Is like read to my kids,
okay.
Put them to sleep and then binge TV.
We have room,
and we are ready for this change in our relationship.
What are we watching right now?
We were watching "The Bachelor".
And my favorite thing about The Bachelor is
that every time they get to a new hotel,
everyone acts like they've never been to a hotel before,
like they definitely get a deal or something,
and they're just like...
(Amy screaming)
Okay, actually I'll do it here.
The first time they walk in the room, they're just like...
(Amy screaming)
(everyone laughing)
You know, and you are like,
"Have these people never been in a hotel?"
That was weird.
(upbeat music)